so we had some good feedback from the
video on one equipped er but some
questions about basically what it is
that it does from an encryption point of
view and that actually quite an
interesting topic because what it does
is similar obviously slightly different
but similar to what most of the other
ransomware does as well so I thought we
cover pretty much the full of the basics
of what it is that ransomware dubs
beyond just it has a private key in it
encrypts your data which is obviously
the sort of the assumption will perhaps
start with a look at a really rubbish
one that I'm making up as I go along and
we'll kind of build it up into a system
that kind of makes sense and you'll see
hopefully how it uses both symmetric and
asymmetric or public key cryptography
combined to try and produce an effective
exploit okay so let's imagine that I
wanted to write a piece of ransomware
which I don't I should I should add I
don't think people should be liking
ransomware but but knowing a bit about
how it works is quite a good way of
understanding a bit about how
cryptography works there's really two
major types of cryptography that we see
a lot of like symmetric encryption and
asymmetric encryption I will put hash
functions aside for one for one day so
symmetric encryption quite simply have
one key for encryption and the same key
for decryption all right so a AES is a
good example of any symmetric block
cipher that people use a lot of at the
moment a symmetric encryption or public
key cryptography is where we have a
separate key for encryption and another
key for decryption and that has numerous
benefits in some circumstances and
drawbacks in other circumstances so what
one equipped ER does is combine both of
these things to try and get a solution
that first of all will run offline so if
they're not connected to their command
and control servers they can still in
click your disk and theoretically
decrypt it later
although the juries are whether they
actually will bother so let's imagine
that we're writing to man somewhere
right the first thing we could do is we
could choose an emetic encryption cipher
like AES right as we could say what
we're going to use a year and to do that
we need a symmetric key so I could
developer I'm programming this up I
could write a piece of code that
searches through all the files on
someone's hard disk and for files of a
certain type I could replace that file
with a copy of that file that's been
passed through this cipher so I need to
come up with a key so I generate the key
- let's call it KS right for the
symmetric key the difficulty here is if
I'm going to use this key to encrypt
people's data it needs to have access to
it so either this needs to be sent to
the malware as it's running right in
which case there's going to be a
compromised dead the keys been sent over
network hopefully people researchers
could find it on the network and then
use it to decrypt someone's files
without having to pay any money
alternatively it's a very naive approach
you could just bury it inside the code
while people do this a lot all right
there are actual ransom waves that have
done this it's not the best approach
so you basically put this string KS
somewhere in the code and then the
ransomware is able to encrypt it and
when it wants to decrypt the files all
right now obviously that's not a good
solution because anyone disassembling
this code right and researchers do this
within minutes of code being released
will immediately find this string and
then tell everyone all at the keys in
this file well let's just decrypt it
this way and there lies another tool
which uses the same function and the
same key all right so that's not a good
solution to improve on this slightly we
can bring asymmetric encryption in right
so this is our first attempt I'm working
my way towards something competent right
so don't judge me yet so in asymmetric
encryption we have two keys right we
have a public key and a key private okay
now as long as the private key is kept
secret then in some ways we can encrypt
everyone's files with the public key and
when they play the ransom give them the
private key that's that's kind of a
general idea so early land somewhere
worked this way so when when the
ransomware started it would generate a
public and private key pair it would
send the private key off to a server
somewhere to hold it for ransom and then
it would encrypt everything with the
public key this usually uses RSA there
are other options and we won't talk
about the mathematics of RSA except to
say that it's been very very difficult
to calculate this private key given only
this one so if you're not watching this
when it gets installed this private key
is gone and all you can see is the
public key
and then you're in a bit of trouble now
there's a few downsides to this the
first is that asymmetric encryption is
quite slow right the mathematics
involved in RSA is it's not too bad on a
computer but we do it generally for
smaller messages if you were trying to
include a lot of someone's files with
this it would take quite a long time and
also you have to have a connection to
your commander control server if you're
malware is running and let's say they're
temporarily not on a Wi-Fi or something
like this then what happens is it tries
to upload this private key and it can't
so one of two things happens then either
it has to stop or it just encrypts
everything with the public key and we
lose the private key or the private key
has to be temporarily stored on a disk
which isn't going to work well for
holding it for ransom right none of
these solutions are very very good so
that isn't a very good solution either
like it's a bit slow and there's an
issue of trying to upload this to a
command control server and how we're
going to do that so what modern
ransomware does and this is not
exclusive to ransom where lots of
encryption schemes work this way is a
hybrid encryption scheme where the
majority of the encryption so the actual
encryption of your files will be done
with AES or some symmetric cipher and
that key will be protected by public key
cryptography so you're holding one of
these private keys for ransom and when
you get it back you can vend unencrypted
k-x and unencrypted files that's the
idea so this is what one equipped to
does so one equipped when it's off in a
directory and it starts undoing
undertaking lots of different tasks one
of the tasks it does is start up threads
for trying to spread itself using the
eternal blue exploit but the majority of
the work in terms of encryption is
separate to that and what it will do
from inside its own executable it will
extract a zip file which is also
encrypted it would decrypt this using a
password and then it will extract those
folder files now they hold things like
hard coded Bitcoin addresses that we
know about that you're supposed to be
paying this mansome hard coded public
keys of the server which I'll talk about
in a moment
thus the addresses of the Tor addresses
of the server for the tor hidden
services it extract all of these things
and then it gets to work encrypting your
files so the first thing it does is it
generates an RSA key pair if I start a
new page then then we won't be confused
with my
but essentially I'm making up with the
go along so if you solve that Rubik's
Cube since we're here I changed a couple
of pieces around
I haven't solved a go through yet I
could but I like to annoy people with
having it unsolved on the shelf it also
takes me quite a long time so I'm okay
so when one equip two installs itself
and it starts running it needs to
generate some keys but it's going to use
to encrypt your files the first thing it
does is generate a public and private
key pair for bits in section and these
are for the client all right so let's
call them C pub and C prime it so we've
generated a public key and a private key
right now these are 2048 bit RSA keys
skipping over the math a little bit to
try and calculate the private key if we
didn't have it we would have to solve a
very large integer factorization problem
which is not happening
might survive to say so normally what a
mountain way would do now is with this
private key off to a command-and-control
server
delete it so that we never get it back
unless we pay a ransom and then encrypt
everything with this public key all
right but in a hybrid encryption scheme
we work slightly differently stored
inside the executable is a server's
public key this is a command and control
server so this that we have here in s
hub now this public key has an
associated private key but we have no
idea what it is right it's stored
somewhere on one of those command and
control servers or all of those command
and control servers and these were
generated when the ransomware was
created by a while ago so the client
public and private keys are generated on
the fly for every time it installs
itself on anyone's machine the server's
public key is stored inside the
executable and it's always the same and
it's associated with a service private
key hidden somewhere else that we
haven't got access to if only we did
it's worth mentioning at this point that
if we could find the server and get this
private key that would be good news
right we could decrypt everyone's around
ransoms files perfect it's hidden on the
dark web right so the onion addresses
that are supplied hard coded into one a
krypter
point to servers somewhere on the planet
but we don't really know where right we
will deal with hidden services on
another video because I think it's a
real interesting topic what the client
then does what one equipped ER does it's
got to try and protect this
key so that it can hold it to ransom so
what it does is it encrypts it with the
server's public key so let's say it
takes these down here and it produces F
pub of C private like this is my strange
notation that I'm sort of making up this
is kind of right business so this is
encryption right and we've encrypted
this private key with the public key all
right so now it's totally useless it's
completely mangled we can't use it
remember that in RSA these perform the
opposite tasks so for example if I had
all my files encrypted with C pub I
could decrypt them all again with C
private right so that needs to preserve
so the malware needs to stop me from
getting to that file which is done now
by encrypting it we can't decrypt it
again because we don't have the server's
private key that's the issue here right
so then what happens is for all files
the client will generate a F key which
will call kf4 file right and encrypt the
file with KF then so we're going to
store in essence C pub of K F and K F
okay so let's look at what I've just
written here each client has its own
public and private key pair right now
that's important because theoretically
if one person paid the ransom and they
said them let's say the shared private
and public key pair then everyone you
seem to pay the ransom one's problems
going away right that's not a foolproof
solution so what we do we generate an
okay we generate a KF AES key for every
single file then we encrypt the file
with that so let's just draw that in so
it makes it makes it sense KF file right
so we encrypt the file with KF then we
store that file on disk and we attach to
it that key so that it can be undone but
we hold it to ransom by encrypting it
with our clients public key so let me
run this which files are all in
encrypted with a smash it key so they're
encrypted quickly yep but then that
symmetric key is been encrypted with a
brand new generated asymmetric key pair
yeah which is encrypted with the
public-key so that only the server can
be tricked exactly right
so there's a kind of chain of decryption
here that we would have to solve if we
wanted to undo all this and get our
files back would return us just one file
on the disk to get our file back we need
to decrypt it with KF right which is a
symmetric key
unfortunately KF has been encrypted with
this public key here for the client so
we need to work out what the private key
for the client is unfortunately again
the private key has been encrypted with
the public key of the server so the only
way we can find this private key is to
ask the server for its private key or
more likely ask the server to decrypt it
for us and send it back so you can
imagine a situation where you paid your
ransom like someone on the other end
decided that was ok and you were going
to have you're going to get your files
back so to be clear you shouldn't pay
the ransom because it encourages crime
and there's no guarantee they'll do this
and in fact we've want to click - it
looks like they're not really bothering
right I don't partly because there's a
few implementation issues it's not clear
whose bitcoins you're paying - it should
have had you should have had a so most
ransomware will have a Bitcoin assigned
for your client so when it generates
these keys it will also generate a
Bitcoin address right so theoretically
this is all automated you would pay the
ransom and then theoretically they would
choose to they look at that Bitcoin
address and go okay yes someone's paid
will send them back the private key
their private key not the case here
right it seems to be kind of manual and
in lock come is anyone's actually doing
it but I can sympathize with people who
have had their files encrypted right
it's one thing to say don't do it don't
do it but you can imagine if you were in
a situation where your family photos
have been encrypted you might be quite
desperate to get in the back um so
hypothetically if someone paid a ransom
and it was going to give it back what
would happen is the client would send
off this encrypted private key right
which it doesn't know anymore to the
server and the server would decide okay
they're allowed their files back for
whatever reason and would decrypt this
with their private key so s proof right
which I'll put in here s private SPR B
right so they decrypt our client private
key with their server private key and
send it back over the network like this
is all happening
tor by the way nothing going over the
open network we then have this private
key back again which we can use to
decrypt our K F which we can use to
decrypt our file and then it just
iterates through all the files doing
that process so you can see that the
thing they're actually holding to ransom
is the fact that we don't know this
private key and they've encrypted our
private key the benefit of this approach
is you get the speed of AES which over a
bunch of files on a disk is unbelievably
quick somewhere around I think seven
hundred megabits per second of
encryption rate I think on on a decent
Intel machine with AES instructions on
it you get that benefit but you also
have the benefit that the private key
but sort of the master key as it were it
held only on the server and never needs
to be sent to anyone and the only way to
undo all of this encryption is to know
what that is and the other bonus is but
you don't have to be online to do any of
this
some man somewhere if it can't connect
to the command and control server will
immediately shut down which is nice of
them I suppose because it means they're
not going to encrypt your files if they
know you can't get them back but this
doesn't do anything like that this
encrypts your files first ask questions
of a server later so if the command and
control server disappear there is no
hope because this private key is gone
that's the idea
surely at some point this AES key is in
the clear because it's dead again yeah
and so is this private key right so at
some point while it's running this
private key will exist and before it's
encrypted it will be in memory now
there's a few problems with first of all
it's way too late for most people right
but theoretically if antivirus is being
vigilant that might help but but not
really the other thing is that it's
quite hard to access memory for other
processes because of fairly good
security measures in Windows and Linux
and any other operating system but
separate out processes from one another
so really this is operating in its own
address space it's quite hard for
anything else to sort of get in there
and quickly look at the keys and stick
them in a file in that time period so
really that isn't I don't think an
avenue of research in terms of trying to
fix this problem much better to do
things like the web-based sinkhole that
stopped it running completely and then
keep a vigilant eye out for new variants
show up you know daily now is there any
way of working out how its generating
those keys and using that technique if
it was using a poor encryption library
right then maybe there will be a
weakness that you could use right as it
is to generate these keys it's using the
windows standard encryption library
which is not bought it's like it's
perfectly good so that's a that's going
to be a problem the best bet at this
stage of getting your files back is not
paying a ransom
it's hoping that someone will find this
server the real location of it and
extract this master key at that point
everyone else a tool will be released
within a day but just does all this put
it reverse process and solve the whole
problem this has happened in the past to
ransomware that's been brought down
I believe cryptolocker for example was
an early ransomware but when they
finally brought down the server they
also extracted the master key and were
able to publish tools to undo everything
there's no guarantee that will happen in
this case right the dark web makes it
quite hard to find these servers
especially if for example the massive
publicity surrounding this has caused
them to essentially just do a runner
maybe not even I mean I think the
servers are still running but you know I
don't know but what the end game for
this is we don't know will they find the
servers won't they will this just all to
disappear and unfortunately some people
have lost some files we'll have to wait
and see how doing backups yes what was
the best way to back up then okay hang
on you put me on the spot now so the
best way to do backups is multi-location
right so not a single hard disk because
it might die but also not to hard disk
sitting next to each other in case your
house falls down and smashes our hard
this cloud storage is very good because
they have this multi-site that done as
we built in if you don't mind giving
your file to them and paying their costs
right so some common I use some
combination of cloud storage and hard
disks and burning to blu-ray and things
like this